KYLE KEANE: All right.
So on a scale of zero to 10, how
energetic is everyone feeling?
I'm going to count to
three and then-- hey,
is that a super familiar face?
Hey.
Howdy.
Yeah, so on the
count of three, I
want everyone to say a
number between zero and 10
about how much energy you're
feeling about being here today.
So I don't want to project.
I'm feeling a little
bit low energy.
So I don't want to project.
So if you guys
feel good, tell me
you feel good so that I know
that my internal state is not
your state.
It's really important to
gauge these things sometimes.
All right.
So 1, 2, 3.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KYLE KEANE: All right.
There was a gradient in this
direction, but all right.
That's good.
Nobody went down to three,
which is about where I am.
Unless there was any threes
out there-- if there are,
come talk to me after.
There's support services.
And we can go together and
get a little bumped up.
But yeah, so again, I want
social interaction today.
So we're going to do something
quicker than yesterday,
but I want people to
introduce yourself and say
a random animal and make that
animal's noise if you can,
or attempt to.
So I'm Kyle and-- it
doesn't even have to--
I'm trying to make it
rhyme or have alliteration.
Doesn't even have to be that.
I'm going to say
Kyle, cat, meow.
That's most-- OK, meow.
That's more like
an actual cat says.
That's not what we
represent cats saying.
Yeah, so try to look
around and figure out
people's names and maybe
one other thing, something
personal about us that we can
get to know some type of thing.
And what's a good--
AUDIENCE: What we want
to eat for dinner.
KYLE KEANE: Great.
All right.
What you're hoping to
have for dinner tonight.
Thank you.
All right, so Kyle,
probably Thai food,
but that's because
it's my default
and I never know what
else to do, so Thai food.
All right.
So with you guys--
AUDIENCE: I'm Mark.
I'm probably going to end up
having pasta tonight, maybe
Soylent.
Who knows?
We'll see.
And [INTERPOSING VOICES]
KYLE KEANE: horrified.
AUDIENCE: You really
drink Soylent?
AUDIENCE: I survived off of
that for weeks at a time.
AUDIENCE: Just like just
Soylent, nothing else?
AUDIENCE: Just Soylent.
Yeah.
KYLE KEANE: Anybody not
know what Soylent is?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Not Soylent Green.
KYLE KEANE: Not Soylent Green.
No.
AUDIENCE: It's like a
better version of Ensure.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
KYLE KEANE: Right.
But it has all the nutrients
that a human needs to survive.
And you just drink it and you
never have to worry about food.
But-- AUDIENCE: It's
easy and it's cheap.
Those are all the requirements
a student should--
and my favorite animal
is the prairie dog.
I don't really know
what sound they make,
but I think it's
like [CLICKING]....
KYLE KEANE: Aw.
That was nice.
Cool.
All right.
Thank you.
So today, at some point, you're
going to break up into groups.
And at some point, I'm
going to do a pop quiz
and you're going
to have to tell me
the names of the
people in your group,
because I forgot to
do that yesterday
and I wonder how
many of you know
the names of the people
that were in your group.
I'm not going to ask
you about yesterday,
but today I will
ask you about that.
So I mean, some of you
may have known the names.
Thumbs up if you did.